welcome to best car fixes this is
muhammad harold there is please
subscribe share unlike infinity 2020 q
x 6 0.
let's try to see if we can program a key
like all key lost or no key available or
no proxy available
like this
the key
you have an insert inside
and it this is the part number
infinity and nissan they are the same
so let's go ahead and see if we can do
something i'm going to go to emo
and i will accept
then i will go to
infinity i go to asian car
infinity here and let's see if we'll be
able to communicate with
i'm not sure but uh i'm gonna do my best
i'm gonna go automatic selection
open and close the driver open and close
the driver door and close it door lock
unlock
good
so now i'm gonna go say okay
hazard light is on you're gonna push a
button here for the hazard light see
and we're gonna wait
just a little bit
now we are
27 we continue
for this one be sure you have internet
available
because if you don't have no wi-fi no
internet
it's not going to help so i'm going to
quick open
my
hotspot
you don't have hot spot believe me
you're gonna be you're gonna be in
trouble in the middle of programming
programming is 11.99 which is good
this is 20 20 20
you know toyota after
2016-17 they changed their algorithm
i'm not sure about the infinity but
let's try
11.99 hopefully it's good if it's not
we're gonna put a really charger
you see my wi-fi is good now my hotspot
now i'm 83 percent
and this one here in the back
when you push this one you slide it
you're going to take the
the the key inside
so now here what you need to do i'm
going to do my scan just to be sure that
everything is healthy
smart key
there is two key registers and 20 digit
authorization code calculation supported
so the machine support
the calculation which is not bad we are
66 percent
so
okay all key lost
three step start
i'm gonna put like this so i know which
one i use
exterior option will erase all the keys
turn the ignition off turn the hazard on
open the closed driver door
ignition must be off
say okay
place the back of the key
back of the key
this mark again is the ignition and
press ok
ok
did it yes
now we go online
checking the network that's why i say
internet is very important
and this one i leave it like this all
the time
if everything is okay you have internet
it will go into programming six section
if you are not sure
look at it an issue but i believe it's
okay
[Music]
you can go here and check your internet
is connected
network check
it takes some time but we're gonna wait
okay everything good press and push
button
now operate according to the following
procedure press push button ignition
switch for two seconds or more and turn
the ignition on
so i'm going to push this one until the
light is on
push it
good
ignition is on
oh let me stop all this
okay
yes ignition is on yes
now it will tell you to turn it on
success now
we are start we're gonna start
programming those module now
the first thing to do is to turn the key
off and then push it and put this key on
it
turn the key off
for three seconds the same procedure we
did it for
then click ok
press the push button once and attach
the smart key that need to program to
start button with
where the server light up and
automatically we're going to see if this
the instrument will light up i'm going
to push here like this
and then put this one
yes
two three four five
that's me this one is already registered
i say yes
so this programming is success i'm gonna
leave this one here i'm gonna take this
one
do you wanna program another one i say
yes
dr ignition off wait three seconds i
turn it off
okay awful
okay
turn off i'm gonna wait three seconds
now i'm gonna do this one too
so i'm gonna push
one
put the key
yes
beautiful
we're going to say yes
yes do you want to program another one i
say no
turn the key off
i'm going to leave this one here
push it one time more
press the start button and put attach
key
okay i'm gonna start button put this one
so now i say okay
i say okay
turn the ignition off
so okay
key programming succeed perform the
following open and close the driver door
click unlock unlock
once start the engine and wait five
seconds
unlock
i'm gonna be able to start the car
i don't want to start the car because i
don't know what happened
but i know everything is good now
supposed to get a message there i say
key is programmed
i'm gonna try to see if i can start it
where's the break
let the break or what
beautiful
the car start
everything look okay
so
we learn from here
also
that
if you need to program this one it's
going to take you the same step that we
did for 2015 to 2020
infinity q50 nissa maxima ultima all the
things they follow the same rule that's
one
we are able to do 2020
now the next thing is to
take this holder
the insert it looks the same only they
make it a little bigger to correspond
with the other one
what we need again
we know that you must have internet and
you know that you have to be sure follow
the step
one by one if you don't follow the steps
it may not work fine
and we know that
whether it's infinity q50
or
all those car they're supposed to be the
same
infinity nissan
q50 all the procedure is the same
this is a beautiful car
and this is like seven seat
how big why nice
please subscribe share and like i'll see
you in another video this is